I don't know if you've noticed it but
there's a slight undertone of racism to
Donald Trump's campaign no really and of
course when I say slight undertone I
mean something approximately the size of
the sky two examples that may have flown
under your radar but maybe you should
get tattoos of them a prominent
african-american politician has on a CNN
podcast described birtherism as quote
[ __ ] racism that politician is
michael steele former chairman of the
Republican National Committee and while
his assertion is correct it would carry
a little more weight if he had not been
chairman of the Republican National
Committee from January 2009 through
January 2011 exactly when that [ __ ]
racism that is birtherism first
flourished in the Republican Party under
his watch a mantle that would largely be
taken up by Donald Mr [ __ ] racism
himself Trump and then there's Kathy
Miller Kathy Miller chair of the Trump
campaign in Mahoning County Ohio
that's Youngstown just about halfway on
the drive from Cleveland to Pittsburgh
she was interviewed by the British
newspaper The Guardian and she knows who
is to blame for racism in this country
Barack Obama growing up in Ohio in the
60s Kathy Miller says there was no
racism there was no segregation no civil
rights protests quote I never
experienced it I never saw that as
anything growing up as a kid there was
no racism believe me we were just all
kids going to school I don't think there
was any racism until Obama got elected
we never had problems like this now with
the people with the guns and shooting up
the neighborhoods and not being
responsible citizens that's a big change
and I think that's the philosophy that
Obama has perpetuated on America no I'm
not making any of this up
to let miss Miller continue quote if
you're black and you haven't been
successful in the last 50 years it's
your own fault you've had every
opportunity it was given to you you've
had the same schools everybody else went
to you had benefits to go to college
that white
kids didn't have you had all the
advantages and didn't take advantage of
it it's not our fault
certainly chairperson Miller is a living
metaphor for his campaign she has
resigned now but she is the Trump
campaign she is him she is all of them
living a whole life made up of if it
didn't happen to me it didn't happen and
to quote Blazing Saddles you've got to
remember that these are just simple
farmers these are the people of the land
the common clay of the new West you know
morons
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space